watching message from the Widow of the  dancer and TV personality and  inspiration to a lot of us known as  Twitch in her first social media posts  and Stephen boss's death last week  Allison holker shared this on Instagram  a selfie of The Smiling couple holker  left a short but powerful message my one  and only oh how my heart aches we miss  you so much  twitch was last seen in this Instagram  video he shared on December 11th doing  what he and she were known best for  dancing  just two days later he was found dead in  a motel room in Los Angeles the death  was ruled to Suicide twitch was 40 years  old since then there has been an  outpouring of support for holker and  their three children